>> Tucker: STATE WRESTLING
CHAMPIONSHIP IN TEXAS JUST
WRAPPED UP FOR THE SECOND
YEAR IN A ROW.
THE WOMEN'S CLASS 6 A
110-POUND DIVISION WAS WON
BY MAC BEGS.
MACK, THAT'S RIGHT, ALTHOUGH
BIOLOGICALLY FEMALE MAC IS
TRANSITIONS TO MALE AND PART
OF THAT TRANSITION TAKES
TEST TESTOSTERONE AND
STEROIDS.
WE ASKED MARK STEYN TO COME
ON AND EXPLAIN IT MARK, THIS
STEAMS
SEEAMS
SEEMMS
SEEMSS
SEEMS LIKE.
THEY ARE A SLIPPERY SLOPE
DESPITE CLAIMS TO THE
CONTRARY.
WHY IS GIRLS SPORTS NOT
OVER?
BOYS HAVE A MASSIVE PHYSICAL
BIOLOGICAL ADVANTAGE IN A
LOT OF SPORTS.
AND IF YOU ALLOW BOYS TO
COMPETE AS GIRLS, THEN WHAT
HAPPENS TO GIRLS?
>> WELL, THERE IS NO GIRLS
SPORTS THEN.
BUT, YOU'RE RIGHT.
JUST TO GO BACK TO WHAT YOU
SAID, TUCKER, THIS MAY SEEM
TRIVIAL AND THE SLIPPERY
SLOPE.
IT ISN'T ACTUALLY.
I WOULD SAY THIS IS ACTUALLY
ONE OF THE BIGGEST STORIES
OF OUR TIME.
PERHAPS THE BIGGEST.
BIGGER THAN THE BUDGET
DEFICIT OR WHATEVER.
YOU USE THE WORD GENDER IN
THE INTRODUCTION.
IN MY DAY WE USED TO TALK
ABOUT THE SEXES.
WHEN I WAS A SCHOOL BOY,
NAME, DATE OF BIRTH, SEX,
AND EVERY ERRANT SCHOOL BOY
WOULD PUT SEX, YES, PLEASE.
IT WAS A STANDARD BOYHOOD
JOKE AND ALL THE GIRLS PUT
SEX FEMALE AND THAT WAS HOW
IT WAS DIVIDED AND SOMEWHERE
ALONG THE WAY SEX, THE TWO
SEXES WERE ABOLISHED AND
REPLACED BY THE WORD GENDER.
AND IN THE COURSE OF THAT WE
LOST NOT JUST THE GREAT
SCHOOL BOY JOKE IN A SENSE
WE LOST THAT CLEAR
DISTINCTION AND SO WE HAVE
REPLACED THE TWO BIOLOGICAL
SEXES WITH A MULTIPLICITY OF
GENDERS.
AND THE ABOLITION OF THE
SEXES IS, IN FACT, NOT A
SMALL THING.
AND THIS -- AND THE POINT OF
THIS WRESTLING COMPETITION,
TEXAS HAS RESPONDED TO SOME
OF THESE MODISH FANCIES BY
SAYING NO, ONLY BIOLOGICAL
GIRLS CAN COMPETE IN GIRLS
SPORTS AND BIOLOGICAL BOYS.
THIS IS A WAY OF SAYING
WHATEVER DO YOU.
WHATEVER LAWS YOU PASS TO
PROTECT TRADITIONAL SEX
ROLLS AND GIRLS SPORTS AND
BOYS SPORTS.
WE ARE GOING TO RIDE A COACH
AND HORSES THROUGH THIS
ANYWAY AND YOU ARE DONE AND
IT'S OVER.
IT IS ONE OF THE BIGGEST
STORIES OF OUR TIME.
>> Tucker: I AGREE WITH THAT
I THINK IT HAS PROFOUND.
THAT'S WHY WE DO THIS STORY
NOT FOR ANY PURIENT REASON.
I'M FASCINATING BY THE IDEA
THAT A SMALL GROUP OF PEOPLE
CAN DETERMINE WHAT THE REST
OF US ARE ALLOWED TO SAY OUT
LOUD ABOUT EVEN BIOLOGY.
WE'RE NOW REQUIRED TO LIE
ABOUT BIOLOGY AND WE ARE
PUNISHED IF WE DON'T.
AND HOW DOES THAT HAPPEN?
NO ONE REALLY BELIEVES.
THIS ONLY ABOUT 8 PEOPLE DO
AND THEY ARE IN CONTROL.
HOW?
>> WELL, I THINK THAT'S WHAT
THAT'S THE OTHER FASCINATING
THING.
YOU KNOW, IF YOU ARE A
CLIMATE SKEPTIC THEN THE
LEFT DEMONIZE YOU AND SAY
YOU ARE ANTISCIENCE.
WE ARE ABOLISHING BIOLOGY IN
A LOT OF THIS.
WHAT I FIND INTERESTING
ABOUT THIS.
AS YOU SAY THERE IS ONLY YOU
SAY ONLY 8 PEOPLE BELIEVE
THIS.
HOW MANY BELIEVE IT THEY ARE
THE ONLY PEOPLE THAT MATTER
IN THE UNITED STATES AND
EUROPE AND EVERY OTHER
ADVANCED SOCIETY.
FRIMPLE, IF I WERE TO
MISGENDER THIS GIRL WHO IS
TRANSITIONING INTO A BOY.
IS THERE WOULD BE A TWITTER
STORM ABOUT HOW I
MISGENDERRED HIM OR HER AND
THAT WAS DISGRACEFUL AND
CELEBRITIES GET HOUNDED INTO
THIS GIRL TRANSITIONING INTO
BOY ON DRUGS THAT INCREASE
HER STRENGTH AND RUINED THE
FOR ALL THE UNDRUGGED,
UNSTEROIDED GIRL WRESTLERS.
AND WHAT I PARTICULAR RYE
SENT ABOUT THIS STORY,
TUCKER, IS THE LOSS OF
SEEMINGNESS IN OUR SOCIETY.
IF SOMEBODY WANTS TO
TRANSITION INTO A BOY OR
TRANSITION INTO A GIRL,
GREAT.
BUT, MAYBE THAT MEANS YOU
HAVE TO GIVE UP THE
WRESTLING.
THAT YOU CAN'T HAVE
EVERYTHING TAKE UP THE
VIOLIN.
NOT WRECK A STATEWIDE SPORT
FOR ALL THE OTHER
PARTICIPANTS.
>> Tucker: STEEP AND TRUE.